歡迎收看泛科學新聞
這是第 37 集
讓我接著感謝另一百位泛糰會員
讓我們每週都製作的很起勁
然而這個節目第二季將在 40 集告一段落
畢竟天下無不散的Party
但如果你希望在 2026 年
看到第三季的泛科學新聞
請務必在本月底前透過加入會員
讓我們能有繼續製作的底氣
我們已經離會員目標很近
就等你了
감사합니다 (gamsa-hamnida)
你
是不是擔心在AI時代脫隊
我們不可能讓你落單
泛科學的姊妹頻道【泛科學院】
跟 YouTube Learning 一起做了三堂
「真的免費」的AI課程
重點是
看完還能拿
YouTube Learning × Google for Education
共同頒發的官方聯名證書
給國小高年級到國中生的
是《少年們的 AI 簡報影音大作戰》
讓 AI 幫你做出一支
又帥又有梗的自我介紹影片
如果你是高中生、大學生
或是被報告摧殘的上班族
《AI 神隊友》會教你怎麼用
Gemini 做研究、做筆記、整理資料
甚至把整個學習流程自動化
老師跟家長也別錯過
《AI 教學手札》找來五位
Google for Education 認證教師
教你怎麼在課堂與家裡
用 AI 教書、備課、陪孩子學英文
甚至自動批改小孩的作文
用AI 幫自己變強這件事
不是空談
我們真的準備好了
剩下的就看你要不要點資訊欄的連結而已
快點 快點
科學家又解開了那個沒有人在乎的問
蛤
身為男性貓奴的你
請誠實回答我
你回家的時候
你家的貓是不是特別熱情
對著你喵喵叫個不停
你可能以為這是愛
但貓是一種神祕的液體生物
關於牠們怎麼跟人類「打招呼」的細節
科學家其實並不那麼了解
因為以前的數據大都靠奴才填問卷
但貓奴嘛
稍微被蹭一下
哎呀
腦內就會自動補完戀愛小說
收來的都是主觀濾鏡下的數據
為了搞清楚貓咪到底在想什麼
由土耳其安卡拉大學獸醫系教授
Yasemin Salgirli Demirbas 帶領的研究團隊
決定不再聽傻傻的奴才
說貓有多愛他
他們找了 31 隻家貓
要求奴才回家時戴著 GoPro 或是胸掛攝影機
直接拍下開門那瞬間
最真實的「黃金 100 秒」
研究結果剛發表在
《動物行為學 Ethology》期刊上
團隊逐格分析了這 100 秒內的 22 種行為
像是尾巴有沒有翹高高
有沒有過來磨蹭
還是開始抓沙發等等
結果發現
不管開門回家的奴才是男是女
貓咪過來磨蹭或豎尾巴的機率都差不多
也就是說
在肢體語言上
貓咪是性別平權的
但是
在「講話」這件事上
貓咪就很差別對待了
數據顯示
貓咪在迎接男性奴才時
發出叫聲的頻率
顯著比迎接女性時還要高
平均來說
對著男生會叫 4.3 次
對著女生只會叫 1.8 次
為什麼
科學家認為這其實是一種
你就袂聽啊（Lí tiō bē thiann a）
阮是無法度才一直講
（guán sī bô-huat-tō͘ tsiah it-tit kóng ）
的溝通策略
也就是說女性奴才通常比較敏銳
像是會主動跟貓講話
或是貓咪只要稍微揮個尾巴、眨個眼
女生就懂了
「喔～寶貝餓了嗎？」
雙方已經達到了心電感應的境界
根本不需要開口
貓咪只要維持 super shy super shy
就夠了
而男奴才卻張開了「遲鈍力場」
讀不懂貓細微的肢體語言
貓咪發現「眼神暗示」沒用
「磨蹭」也沒反應
只好切換成「廣播模式」
大吼大叫
但但但
這研究樣本數只有 31 隻
而且地點是在土耳其
團隊自己也承認
土耳其的男性可能因為文化關係
比較少對貓咪展現「柔情似水」的一面
也就是比較矜 khim啦
如果在臺灣
或許就不需要一直叫叫叫了
最後還有一個超級大的盲點
他們竟然沒有紀錄貓「餓不餓」
你想想看
如果那個男生回家
剛好都是放飯時間
那貓對著他大叫
根本不是因為他遲鈍
單純只是因為他是「飼料機」啊
對 有人可能記得這位教授
今年還有另一則研究
就是從 YT 影片發現
大多數的貓是左派
這個
難道只要一直拍貓、看貓
就可以一直發 paper 一直爽嗎
難道我只要一直介紹跟貓有關的研究
流量就會好嗎
蛤 是這樣啊
喔好
想學「瞬間移動」
由亞德拉特星人
痾不對
是德國斯圖加特大學領軍的團隊
最近真的在量子世界辦到了
成果剛發表在《自然-通訊》上
先別黜臭 thuh-tshàu
雖然這 20 年前就做過了
我們也用一整集影片介紹過
但以前都是「簡單模式」
這次德國人挑戰的是不可能的「地獄模式」
蛤
德國地獄模式不就是
不是啦
以前為了怕失敗
通常「作弊」
用同一顆量子點光源發出的光子
避免頻率對不上
而且這光還是在光纖裡跑不遠
損耗很高的近紅外光
根本沒辦法架設長距離量子網路
但這次有兩大首創
第一
首次成功
讓兩顆「完全不同」的半導體量子點光子連線
第二
首次把訊號轉成能跑在
現有光纖網路上的「電信波段」
當然
瞬間移動的不是肉體
而是資訊
比較像是
奪舍
因為量子世界裡
有個鐵律叫「不可複製原理」
所以光子沒力時
不能幫它加油
只能把靈魂
也就是量子態
直接「移魂」到下一個滿血的光子身上
然而傳送需要兩個一模一樣的光子雙胞胎
進行干涉
但「半導體量子點」每一顆的頻率都不同
要它們合作
就像請徐薇老師跟高嘉瑜合唱
それはちょっと、心配ですね
(sore wa chottoshinpai desu ne)
讓這件事卡關很久
這次研究真正的突破
就是請到了「量子百萬修音師」
量子頻率轉換器（QFC）
就像開了超強 Auto-tune（自動調音）
利用特殊的「鈮酸鋰波導」晶體
強制把兩顆頻率不同的光子
調成一樣的 1515 nm 電信波段
而這不只是修音
還直接轉成「最適合長距離光纖」的波段
而且只改音準
也就是頻率
完美保留了歌詞
也就是偏振態的資訊
接著是殘酷的「移魂儀式」
一號量子點產生帶著秘密資訊的「光子 1」
二號量子點則產出一對糾纏的
「光子 2」跟「光子 3」
我們把「光子 2」拉過來跟「光子 1」連結
把「光子 3」丟到遠方去
因為光子2跟3有糾纏關係
不管距離多遠
只要光子2一變
光子3就會瞬間跟著變
好 接著把用量子頻率轉換器修好音的光子 1
和負責連結的光子 2
一起送進光纖分束器
因為轉換器把它們變得一模一樣
它們發生了「雙光子干涉」
混在一起
混到連宇宙都分不出誰是誰
就在這個身分混淆的瞬間
它們一起撞上探測器
這一撞
就是要殺死它們
就像休·傑克曼為了完成傳送魔術
每次都要讓原本的自己掉進水箱淹死
新的自己才會在遠方出現
量子力學也是這麼殘酷
探測器響起
光子 1 跟 2 被毀滅（吸收）
但這個動作確立了它們的關係
重點來了
因為 2 跟 3 纏結
既然確立了 1 跟 2 的關係
就等於瞬間鎖定了 1 跟 3 的關係
遠方的「光子 3」就在這一刻
繼承了光子 1 的靈魂
結果顯示
移魂儀式的保真度高達 0.721
遠超及格線
雖然這距離僅約 10 公尺
但關鍵在於成功用「調音」解決光源難題
還直接轉成了
能跑長途的電信波段
證明了未來的量子網路
直接用現有的光纖就能跑
這代表由物理定律守護
絕對安全、不被竄改的通訊
離我們更近了
你想用來傳什麼呢
蛤
徐薇老師跟高嘉瑜的合唱
記得傳給我
大家好
我不是 Will
這也不是X調查
但今天要講一個懸宕了 15 年的懸案
關鍵證物
是一隻找不到身體的腳
大家都很熟的「露西」（Lucy）是「阿法南猿」
在 300 多萬年前的東非蹓躂
如果是人類祖母的話
得加上 16 萬個「曾」
但在 2009 年
科學家在衣索比亞的 Burtele 地區
挖到了一樣不得了的東西
一塊 340 萬年前的腳掌化石
這隻腳簡直就是特級咒物
因為露西的腳早就演化成適合在地面走路
大拇指是併攏的
但這隻腳骨卻保留了強大的遠古力量
它的大拇指竟然還可以「對握」
就像猩猩一樣
顯然擁有強大的爬樹能力
由美國亞利桑那州立大學人類起源研究所的
海爾-塞拉西(Yohannes Haile-Selassie)
領軍的團隊
握著這根獨特的腳骨
卻也苦於只有腳骨
現場找不到頭骨、沒有牙齒
只好把它封印在倉庫裡長達 15 年
好在沒有人把它吃了
原本以為這故事就這麼爛尾了
但就在最近
同團隊竟然在發現腳掌的「同一個地層」
只差幾百公尺的地方
挖出了一批新的牙齒和下顎骨化石
研究剛發表在《Nature》上
這下連載重啟
科學家要讓它受肉重生
但不搞咒術
搞技術
他們祭出
「工業級顯微電腦斷層掃描」（Micro-CT）
看穿骨頭內部
發現這副下顎骨
少了一個露西族群特有的標記
叫做「外側孔洞」（lateral corpus hollow）
而且犬齒內部的構造也跟露西完全不同
根據這些解剖學上的特徵
科學家將這些牙齒
歸屬於 2015 年才被命名的新物種
近親南猿（Australopithecus deyiremeda）
為什麼
因為同一個地點、同一個時間層
只有這一種
沒有其他古猿
但這也代表在 340 萬年前
露西並不是唯一的霸主
她有群鄰居就住在五公里外
而且這個鄰居的生活習慣跟她截然不同
科學家驗了牙齒琺瑯質的「碳同位素」
發現這位「近親南猿」
是位堅持只吃 C3 植物的「森林系」饕客
專吃樹葉跟果實
而住在旁邊的露西
則是 C3 加 C4 通吃
連草原上的草都吃
這兩個物種雖然住得蠻近
但因為你吃你的樹
我走我的路
所以沒有互相滅絕
但這也代表
露西所屬的阿法南猿
說不定根本不是我們的直系祖先
這個還留著爬樹外掛的近親南猿
搞不好更接近我們祖先原型的樣子
不過西班牙國家人類演化研究中心
的古人類學家
萊斯利·盧斯科（Leslea Hlusko）
不買單
她認為這所謂的「近親南猿」
牙齒特徵剛好介於
更老的湖畔南猿跟阿法南猿之間
總不能截了一張皮卡丘進化成雷丘
中間發光的圖
然後說這是一隻新的寶可夢叫起丘吧
她懷疑這只是演化過程中的過渡階段
甚至可能只是露西族群裡
長得比較怪、腳比較像猩猩的個體
但研究團隊不是吃素的
雖然近親南猿是吃素的
他們回說
如果是露西族群裡的變異個體
沒道理會集體堅持只吃森林特餐（C3）
而其他人吃雜食自助餐
這種連飲食文化都完全不同的現象
通常就是兩個物種才會有的生殖隔離
這場認祖歸宗的大戲還沒演完
露西真的是我們所有人的直系阿嬤嗎
還是只是遠房阿姨呢
宿儺是虎杖的伯公嗎
羂索是虎杖的媽媽嗎
算了 隨便啦
科學家發現
只要跟 AI 聊個五分鐘
你堅若磐石的政治立場
就可能被動搖
而且是地動山搖
來自 MIT、康乃爾大學與牛津大學的團隊
在《Nature》跟《Science》上同步發表研究
他們在 2024 美國大選
以及 2025 年的加拿大和波蘭大選期間
找來數萬名選民跟 AI 聊天
規模之巨大
簡直是「社會科學界的曼哈頓計畫」
為什麼搞那麼大
我們知道談到政治許多人就是
「我不聽 我不聽」
立場不合的證據通通當作沒看到
這讓傳統政治廣告的效果廢到笑
通常只能改變不到 1% 的選民
但現在 AI 那麼厲害
不免讓人擔心
AI會偷我們個資、抓我們弱點
來個「精準個人化洗腦」
不過這兩篇研究卻發現
AI 根本不需要用上詐騙手段
只要一直「碎碎念」就贏了
這怎麼回事
他們在線上群眾外包平台
招募超過 七萬六千名 受試者
進入這個圖靈測試
科學家先把受試者對於某個議題
比如支持川普或反對迷幻藥的立場
量化成 0 到 100 分
接著丟進一個聊天室
跟 GPT-4 等級的 AI 開始尬聊
重點來了
科學家已經給 AI 植入不同的
「說服戰術模組」
A 組切個資
針對受試者的年齡、性別、種族
量身打造話術
B 組玩情感
用感性故事和道德框架來軟化對方
C 組則用海量的「客觀」事實和證據轟炸
另外再加上完全聊無關主題的對照組
以及無特殊戰術指示
純自由發揮的基本指令組
數萬場辯論後
科學家再測量立場分數的變化
結果原本大家以為最可怕的
「A組個資」戰術
效果只有一點點點
真正的強者是「C組」
當 AI 開啟「資料轟炸模式」
說服力比起基本指令組
高出了 27% 啊
好
既然知道「資料轟炸」是最強策略
那就來看效果囉
他們把這套 AI
拿去挑戰 2024 年美國總統大選
發現在川普對決賀錦麗這個極端戰場上
AI 成功讓川普支持者對賀錦麗的好感度
增加了 3.9 分
賀錦麗支持者對川普則增加了 2.3 分
不要小看這幾分
在一個五五波的選舉裡
這幾分的位移
足夠讓穩贏的候選人回家吃自己
而在麻州迷幻藥合法化公投
這個政黨立場沒那麼死硬的公投議題上
可以改變超過 14.85 分
這會是徹底翻盤啊
甚至
如果啟動全開模式
用最強模型、最強的資料轟炸指令
加上個人化設定和額外的 AI 訓練
針對原本持反對意見的人
AI 可以讓他們的態度
轉變達到驚人的 26.1 分
科學家說這已經是民主破壞等級了
簡單來說
科學家證實要改變一個人的政治信仰
不需要讀心
只需要用超高密度的資訊流
來個「無量空處」就夠了
所以
Are you ready for this sunday night
when wwe champ john cena
defends his title
in this wwe su-su-super slam~slam~slam
但科學家也發現
AI 為了拼「說服力」
當證據不夠用
就開始瞎掰
而且說服力強的 AI 模型越會瞎掰
另外在三個國家實驗中都發現
幫「右派」辯護的 AI
造假機率顯著比左派高
這
你覺得該怎麼解釋好
對
這研究還有個顯著的缺點
那就是大家是被迫跟 AI 聊天
但在現實生活中
能耐著性子看完長篇大論政治文的
恐怕越來越少
而且現實世界中的網軍或公關公司
也不會只用文字
而是會用流行的短影音
找個貌似忠良的中年人
穿著女僕裝
喂 這稿誰寫的
終於證實了
這個長達 5000 萬光年的超級結構
不只自己在轉
還帶著住在裡面的星系跟著一起轉
這項發表在《英國皇家天文學會月刊》的研究
是由牛津大學與劍橋大學領軍的跨國團隊
利用南非最強的
MeerKAT 電波望遠鏡完成的
他們在距離我們
約 4.4 億光年的 COSMOS 場
抓到了一條由星系組成的「巨蛇」
先解釋一下
COSMOS 場不是指整個宇宙（Cosmos）
而是一個天文學家公認的「風水寶地」
這塊天區特別乾淨
沒有銀河系的塵埃擋路
視野好
所以像是哈伯、錢卓拉這些望遠鏡
都喜歡對著這裡猛拍
正因為這裡是
全宇宙被人類看得最徹底的地方
資料最齊
科學家才能挖出這個驚人的結構
這條巨蛇真的很誇張
是目前觀測到「最大的旋轉結構」
長度達到 15 Mpc
也就是大約 4900 萬光年
誒
我們銀河系直徑才 10 萬光年
在它面前簡直就是一粒灰
但最讓科學家興奮的不是Size
而是「它在動」
我們早就知道宇宙中
充滿了這種由暗物質構成的「纖維」
但過去我們以為這些宇宙蜘蛛絲
只是靜止的「高速公路」
雖然有一些間接證據支持它會轉
但不多
但這次不同
研究團隊分析了這條巨蛇纖維上星系的光譜
發現了一種完美的對稱
纖維的一側
星系正在遠離我們（紅移）
另一側
星系正在靠近我們（藍移）
就像在看一支旋轉的鑽頭
數據顯示整條 5000 萬光年的結構
正以每秒 110 公里的速度
進行整體自轉
它的鑽頭
可是突破天際的鑽頭
這可大條了
因為這電光毒龍鑽回過頭來證實了
「潮汐力矩理論」(Tidal Torque Theory)
這個老理論簡單說
就是宇宙誕生初期的引力場並不均勻
就像有人搓了一下
給了這個暗物質纖維一個「初始推力」
讓它們開始旋轉
蛤
哪個人搓的說清楚
好啦 我搓的啦
對不起嘛
這條纖維被科學家稱為「冷纖維」(Cold Filament)
不是溫度低
而是說它的動作「很冷靜、很有秩序」
沒有亂跑亂撞
保留了最原始的旋轉動能
因為裡頭這些星系不只跟著纖維公轉
連它們自己的「自轉軸」
都乖乖地對齊了纖維的方向
對齊的程度
甚至超過了電腦模擬預測的範圍
研究員 Lyla Jung
說這簡直是遊樂園的旋轉咖啡杯
大轉盤（纖維）在轉
上面的咖啡杯（星系）也在轉
而且所有咖啡杯旋轉的角度
都被嚴格規定好了
這天元突破是很帥
但也讓天文學家冒冷汗
因為我們測量宇宙暗物質的方法叫
「弱重力透鏡」
原理是看背後的星系有沒有被扭曲
但大前提是假設背後的星系
是亂七八糟隨機站的
可是現在這篇研究告訴我們
不 它們沒有隨機
它們會被纖維強迫排整齊
這就像你想測量哈哈鏡有多彎
結果發現照鏡子的人
可能故意歪一邊或是真的就長那樣
那你根本分不清楚
到底是鏡子彎還是人歪
如果這種「強迫對齊」在宇宙很常見
那未來的宇宙觀測數據
可能會被嚴重「汙染」
導致畫出來的暗物質地圖全是錯的
雖然我們終於看到這個
5000 萬光年大的鑽頭
但這也提醒我們
源自創世之初的旋轉力量
至今仍在操控著星系的命運
蛤
你突然覺得到處都是漩渦
頭髮也開始捲起來
快逃啊
頭足類演化史上一樁懸宕已久的
「遺產爭奪案」終於解開了
先來介紹主角
就是這位吸血烏賊（Vampyroteuthis）
對 名字很猛
但這傢伙其實是個吃軟飯
不對
是專吃「海洋雪」
也就是海洋垃圾碎屑的邊緣人
被叫吸血鬼
純粹是因為牠全身深紅色
觸手之間還有像斗篷一樣的膜
遇到危險會把身體翻過來
露出像獠牙一樣的刺（觸毛）
虛張聲勢
高唱
I’m not cute anymore
儘管只是假掰
在科學界牠可是地位崇高的「活化石」
牠的家族從侏羅紀就在了
跟恐龍同梯
而且長相幾億年來沒什麼變
再來牠的其他親戚
在恐龍滅絕那時都死光了
只剩牠是全村最後希望
最後
雖然牠現在被歸類在章魚這一掛
也就是八腕總目
但牠身上其實藏著兩條退化的「感應絲」
證明牠保留了祖先
原本有 10 隻腳的特徵
而這次由日本島根大學
以及奧地利維也納大學等機構
組成的跨國團隊聯手
找到了牠是活化石的第四個
也是最強的證據
牠連基因組都是老古董
而且這老古董就是解謎的關鍵
研究成果剛發表在《iScience》期刊上
事情是這樣的
頭足類家族分成兩大派系
一派是「十腕總目」
也就是魷魚
還有來侵略的花枝娘
牠們通常有大約 46 條染色體
另一派是「八腕總目」
也就是章魚哥跟小八那一夥
染色體通常只有 30 條左右
但到底是魷魚把祖先的染色體「切碎」了
還是章魚把染色體「黏起來」了
這讓科學家很頭痛
對
科學家就是會為這種事情頭痛
因此科學家決定定序吸血烏賊的基因組
但為何不早點做
因為吸血烏賊的基因組
簡直是惡夢
它的容量高達 110 億個鹼基對（11 Gb）
將近人類四倍大
而且裡面有高達六成以上
都是一模一樣的重複廢話（重複序列）
這跟要拼一萬片的「純白拼圖」一樣
讓人想罵
感恩的心、感謝有你
既然無法還原出完整的染色體排列
那要怎麼知道它有沒有變
這就是這次研究最精采的地方
科學家改用
「共線性分析（Synteny Analysis）」
來推導真相
簡單來說
因為我也只能簡單說
雖然基因組是破碎的
但科學家發現
在吸血烏賊的這些片段上
基因與基因之間的「線性排列順序」
跟魷魚是高度一致的
也就是說
如果基因 A 跟基因 B
在魷魚身上是鄰居
在吸血烏賊身上它們也依然是鄰居
這證明了吸血烏賊
保留了跟魷魚一樣的染色體結構
但是
當他們拿去跟章魚比對時
發現這種鄰居關係被徹底打破了
在章魚的基因組裡
原本應該相鄰的基因被拆散並重組
這證明了章魚發生了所謂的
「融合與混合（Fusion-with-mixing）」
表示章魚將多條祖先染色體合併
並打亂了內部的基因排序
才變成了現在那 30 條染色體的狀態
這下破案了
章魚都是外星人
痾不是
是代表「46 條染色體」
才是頭足類祖先的「原廠設定」
科學家終於可以放下心中的大石
下次吃烤魷魚跟章魚燒的時候
請帶著敬意
因為你吃的每一口
都見證頭足類
堅持傳統與自行基改的奇蹟
蛤
如果吃到外星人怎麼辦
咬碎一點
以上就是本週的泛科學新聞
如果你喜歡今天的內容
或是對哪一則新聞想吐槽
歡迎在下面留言
也別忘了按讚、訂閱、開啟小鈴鐺
下週繼續發現這世界有多荒唐
如果你有拍到什麼
比吸血烏賊還可愛的背景圖
歡迎投稿喔
詳情請看下方的資訊欄